Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritla und ja, das ist Nummer fünfundsiebzig von UKW und das ist äh natürlich die Freitagsausgabe und deswegen ist das äh ein Corona-Weekly.
Ja und ich bin Tim Pritlav und ich sage hallo und äh mit mir ist natürlich Pavel Pavel Meyer, hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim, hallo.
Ja und wir sind wieder hier, um mal so ein bisschen zu reflektieren, was eigentlich so Corona-mäßig so abgeht. Ich merke gerade so ein bisschen, dass mir so ein bisschen die Lust fehlt, äh diese Woche. Weiß nicht, wie es dir so geht, aber.
Ja, bei mir war's eher letzte Woche so. Mhm.
Ja. Ja. Ist aber auch, glaube ich, weil jetzt hier die Stadt langsam aufwacht.
Also man merkt das in Berlin, das jetzt so, Corona ist jetzt so offiziell vorbei, so ist die Stadt irgendwie so drauf, man hat sich so drauf geeinigt, dass das jetzt weg ist.
Naja und ich habe so ein bisschen meine Zweifel, dass es das ist. Es gibt da noch nicht so richtig die Evidenz dafür.
Hören, sehen in zwei Wochen äh wissen wir's. Ähm tja ähm meine ansonsten wollen wir gleich in die Zahlen einsteigen.
Ja, ich denke, wir können gleich in die Zahlen einsteigen, weil das ist so ein bisschen das das Ding, ne, die Zahlen, das ähm ist so der entscheidende Faktor.
Und ähm daran wird man erstmal so ablesen können, was denn jetzt die Wahrheit ist. Hoffe ich zumindest. Kann man?
Ja, also ähm so Deutschlandweit ist der RWT jetzt ziemlich weit.
So bei null Komma acht war sogar etwas unter null Komma acht gestern, ist jetzt irgendwie ein Ticken kleiner Ticken gestiegen, aber,
trotzdem ja gab's sowas seit ewigen Zeiten nicht mehr also selbst im.
Februar ja waren wir die ganze Zeit über null Komma acht aber ja also von daher sieht's gut aus die Zahlen fallen so, allerdings.
Nicht,
leider die Todeszahlen äh die Todesfallzahlen, die sind immer noch bei zwölfhundertachtzig in äh sieben Tagen, das ist immer noch deutlich über tausend und die gehen auch,
nur ganz, ganz langsam zurück, also nicht wirklich mit der Inzidenz und ähm.
Werden wir sehen, also eigentlich müsste es hoffentlich äh bald da auch.
Abwärts gehen eigentlich ja eigentlich so.
Ab heute äh oder ab morgen müssten eigentlich die Zahlen bei den Toten äh äh langsam auch deutlich äh beginnen,
zu sinken, so nach halt vor genau zwanzig Tagen, nämlich auch vor einundzwanzig Tagen.
Äh hat nämlich äh ja das große Sinken der Inzidenzen begonnen äh und.
Ja, wir sind jetzt bei neunundsechzig und wenn das so weitergehen würde, dann sind wir eigentlich ähm.
So ja in ein, zwei Wochen ähm sind wir fast überall unter den fünfzig, die.
Ja zwar eigentlich keine Bedeutung haben, ähm aber äh ja, ist halt eine Zahl so.
Ähm oder deren Bedeutung halt darin besteht, dass dann halt noch mehr gelockert äh werden kann. Ähm.
Ja, ansonsten ähm wenn man dann in die Altersgruppen,
reinguckt, ist da auch nichts wirklich Auffälliges. Die,
gehen halt in allen Altersgruppen runter. Wir sind aber bei den fünf bis vierzehn Jährigen noch immer über hundert bei hundertelf.
Und ähm der Rückgang.
Verlangsamt sich da geringfügig äh so in der Altersgruppe, aber ansonsten alles eher unauffällig und.
Ja, auch die R-Werte in den Altersgruppen, also die pseudor Werte liegen so zwischen null Komma,
sieben, acht und null Komma acht drei und die null Komma acht drei sind eben auch bei den fünf bis äh Vierzehnjährigen konsequenterweise.
Und was die Bundesländer äh angeht äh ja schließt sich da so ein bisschen. Der.
Korridor oder die konvergieren halt äh jetzt grade alle. Also,
Schleswig-Holstein ähm geht nicht mehr ganz so schnell zurück. Die anderen holen bald Schleswig-Holstein ein, wenn das so weitergeht und auch Sachsen und Thüringen,
sind jetzt so ein bisschen näher gekommen mit ihren Inzidenzen, äh so an an Baden-Württemberg äh näher rangekommen, liegen aber beide noch über hundert.
Zumindest nach jedem Publikationsdatum.
So sollten aber auch bald unter hundert fallen, sodass eigentlich in den nächsten Tagen äh die Inzidenz in allen Bundesländern offiziell auch äh unter hundert.
Liegen dürfte und bei den Inzidenzen,
sticht halt gerade vor allem Berlin aus und in Rheinland-Pfalz und,
Schleswig-Holstein ähm sieht es ja ähnlich aus. Da ist es ein bisschen hochgegangen, aber in Berlin ist es äh eben.
Ja äh der größte Anstieg, aber das äh ist jetzt auch nur,
innerhalb äh von einem Tag gewesen, ähm gut, das beruht jetzt auf insgesamt auch letztlich vergleicht der letzten sieben Tage, zu den sieben Tagen davor.
Und insofern äh ja, muss man's nicht überbewerten, aber zumindest gibt's in Berlin erste Signale, dass dort,
die Zahlen äh hochgehen und wenn man dann in die Altersgruppen in Berlin guckt.
Dann sieht man, dass das äh auf die Altersgruppe null bis vier zurückzuführen ist im Wesentlichen.
Ähm ja, äh wo jetzt ausgerechnet seit äh dem.
Ja seit ein paar Tagen, also seit dem siebzehnten Mai sind die Kitas wieder voll geöffnet. Und,
Das muss jetzt aber nicht sein, dass dass es tatsächlich dort jetzt zu,
mehr Infektion kommt, sondern es kann halt auch sein, dass dieser Anstieg darauf zurückzuführen ist, dass jetzt mehr Eltern ihre Kinder hingeschickt haben und die dort getestet worden sind und,
das halt so aufgefallen ist. Aber nun zumindest eine zeitlichen Zusammenhang,
zwischen den Zahlen und den Kita-Öffnungen den gibt es ja.
Also ich habe mir diese R-Werte äh angeschaut auch und ähm war so ein bisschen unruhig geworden. Ja klar ist nur der letzte Tag und wir könnten auch nochmal drüber mutmaßen, inwiefern das vielleicht jetzt mit diesem Chrissi Himmelfahrt.
Äh Wochenende letzte Woche zu tun hat, weil der Donnerstag war ein Feiertag, der Freitag war dann so ein Brückentag.
Mir.
Ähm das sollte ja eigentlich zu weniger,
Zahlen geführt haben, dann so mit den Nachmeldungen und jetzt wieder eine Woche rum, keine Ahnung, meinst du, ist das irgendwie eine Auswirkung haben kann?
Ja, hm.
Weil weil das eher ging halt hoch. So, es ging nicht jetzt auf eins oder so, aber wir haben jetzt kontinuierlich über einen längeren Zeitraum,
auch noch fallende R-Zahlen gehabt. Gut, jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, Hauptsache er bleibt irgendwie unter eins und äh auch wenn er jetzt
da bleibt, wo er jetzt gerade ist, ist irgendwie gut, aber trotzdem hat mich das irgendwie schon unruhig gemacht, weil weil ich einfach dem den Braten nicht traue grade. Also es ist einfach, ich sehe nicht, dass dass wir insgesamt genug Maßnahmen haben oder genug Impfungen haben
als das, was das Geschehen jetzt wirklich so signifikant runterdrückt, trotzdem haben wir irgendwie fallende Zahlen. Und so ein R-Wert, der,
relativ begrüßenswert ist. Und so so sehe ich das gerne bejubeln möchte, bin ich irgendwie so ein bisschen skeptisch bis es irgendwie berechtigt oder ist es unberechtigt?
Gut, die null Komma zwei Abstand jetzt zur Eins. Beim R-Wert,
sind schon mal ein bisschen was. Also das bedeutet, dass wir schon, ich sage mal, ja, eigentlich eine größere Lockerung.
An einer Stelle äh es uns leisten könnten, zu lockern, also beispielsweise die Schulen aufzumachen.
Konnte man sich äh ohne wahrscheinlich den Ehrwert übereinst, aber ja mit eigentlich mit Schulen und äh jetzt Gastronomie und äh Kitas und.
Allem könnte das rechnerisch äh theoretisch zumindest äh ja, könnte das den äh auch erstmal wieder an über die Eins äh nach oben bringen, aber.
Äh ja, wollen wir's wollen wir hoffen, dass das nicht passiert und dass irgendwie Wetter und.
Impfungen verhindern, äh dass der wieder über eins geht.
Aber äh ja hm so meine Hand dafür ins Feuer liegen äh würde ich auch nicht, dass das jetzt.
Durch ist. Also insofern ja ähm.
Wir wir müssen sehen. Wir werden sehen in ein oder zwei Wochen sind wir dann schlauer, wenn wir dann dann sehen wir nämlich erst die Auswirkungen jetzt der Eröffnungen eigentlich so in ein, zwei Wochen.
Und bis dahin, ja, können wir eigentlich nur mutmaßen ähm.
Und sagt, theoretisch äh zumindest aus.
Den Zahlen äh Werken, äh die mir bekannt sind oder wie wie stark jetzt bestimmte Maßnahmen den R-Wert äh beeinflussen müsste,
müssten wir mit sehr hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit äh bald wieder übereins kommen. Ähm wir werden sehen.
Wahrscheinlichkeit über eins kommen mit dem.
Ja beim beim R-Wert, also ein ja.
Also ich rechne eigentlich damit, dass äh jetzt im Zuge der Lockerung das passiert wie lange äh der dann übereins bleibt, äh und ob das dann noch nötig ist, wieder Maßnahmen zu verschärfen.
Dass wird man sehen, weil wir haben ja dann bis dahin auch in der Woche noch ein bisschen mehr Luft,
bei den R-Werten und wenn der sich dann so eher um die eins rumbewegt, dann werden wird's wahrscheinlich auch keine neuen Maßnahmen geben, weil die Inzidenzen dann.
Ja immer noch deutlich unter hundert sein werden, aber es kann, na gut, es fallen ja nicht alle Maßnahmen weg, es bleibt ja noch eine ganze Menge an an Einschränkungen.
Erhalten.
Aber äh ja, das was wegfällt, müsste so nach meiner Erwartung zwischen null Komma zwei und null Komma vier auf den aktuellen R-Wert draufpacken innerhalb von vierzehn Tagen.
Dass wir meine wahrscheinlichste Erwartung, wie viel dann wiederum runtergeht vom R-Wert durch mehr Impfungen und.
Ähm durchs durchs Wetter ganz schwer zu sagen.
Ja ja, also wir stehen so ein bisschen ein bisschen unentschlossen vor den Zahlen.
Kann man mal sagen. Wir wissen, dass wir darin so recht nichts rauslesen können eigentlich.
Naja, außer, dass es halt jetzt gut runtergeht, äh dass Maßnahmen und Impfungen und äh Sommer oder Frühjahr all das zusammenbeschert uns gerade eben.
Diese null Komma acht und äh ja.
Wenn das jetzt so zwei bis vier Wochen so weitergehen würde, sagen wir mal, am Ränder ändert sich nichts. Ein bisschen unwahrscheinlich, aber nur mal davon ausgehen, dann wären wir wo.
Also, wenn das so weitergeht, äh dann wären wir in vier Wochen bei sechzehn irgendwo in der Gegend.
Und würden die fünfzig in einer Woche unterschreiten.
Und wenn das acht Wochen so weitergeht, äh wie, wie jetzt, womit aber, was aber nicht zu erwarten ist, werden wir sogar bei einer Inzidenz von vier runter.
Was halt ungefähr das ist, äh was wir in der ersten, wo wir in der ersten Welle.
Dann im Juni angekommen waren.
Na gut, hoffen wir mal, äh das Beste. Was sagen denn so die Testzahlen.
Sehr können wir denn den Braten überhaupt trauen hier?
Die Testzahlen bestätigen die Rückgänge, ähm die Zahl der Tests ist zwar deutlich zurückgegangen.
Auf,
jetzt eine Million achtzigtausend Tests von eins Komma zwei vier Millionen, also fast dreizehn Prozent weniger Tests in der letzten Woche,
Ähm aber dafür dreißig Prozent weniger positive Tests,
was dann insgesamt jetzt in einer positiven Quote von acht Komma zwo sechs Prozent resultiert.
Dass es immer noch deutlich über dem, was wir.
Jetzt ähm ja im Februar eigentlich hatten Februar, Anfang März.
Ähm da lagen wir äh noch eher so um die sechs, aber ich hoffe, dass wir da bald hinkommen.
Ja und von daher, ja, würde ich sagen, sind die Rückgänge äh weiter real.
Vielleicht aber durch den durch den starken Rückgang der Tests äh möglicherweise äh also ist die Infektions ähm Tätigkeit,
vielleicht nicht ganz so stark gefallen, wie es die, wie es die Zahlen wiedergeben. Auf der anderen Seite,
ist eine sinkende positiven Quote eher immer einen Indiz auch für einen Rückgang der Dunkelziffer, also.
Wir können die Zahlen einfach so nehmen, äh wie sie sind, jetzt die Inzidenzen im Moment grade, also starke Abweichungen durch Änderungen im Testregime oder so gibt's nicht.
Und damit sind wir auch in etwa immer auf der wieder angekommen äh von der ersten Welle
Also jetzt sind wir sozusagen nicht mehr über der ersten Welle, wenn man jetzt mal nur diese positiven Quote
heranzieht, was sich ja bisher als ein recht guter, wenn auch leicht zeitversetzter Indikator für die Aktivität äh erwiesen hat. Wir waren schon mal besser, wie du eben schon gesagt hast, im Februar und im Prinzip könnten wir,
diese Kurve auch immer noch nehmen, also es könnte sozusagen immer noch genauso kommen wie jetzt bei der zweiten Welle, als dann äh alle von Lockerungen geredet haben und jetzt reden ja auch wieder alle von Lockerungen. Nur, dass wir halt,
drei Monate im Vorsprung haben. So, das äh das ist in gewisser Hinsicht das einzige, was besser ist. Oder also.
Also wir sind noch nicht da, wir sind noch längst nicht da, wo wir im Februar äh waren. Und in der Tat, wo es recht, es könnte nochmal genau dieselbe Entwicklung äh wieder
nehmen. Ähm wie es dann im Februar genommen hat, wenn wir es übertreiben.
Ja und das wäre wirklich, ja, das wäre echt so was von frustrierend. Ich meine, vier verlorene Monate, ey, echt für nix und wieder nix.
Ich meine, dagegen spricht halt, dass es sich bisher in anderen Ländern auch noch nicht ankündigt, äh dass es wieder nach oben geht, also ein paar Länder haben ja schon,
so wie vorher gelockert und ich konnte jetzt noch kein Land oder Nachbarland hier äh ausmachen. Ähm.
In der EU, wo ähm ja, die uns da irgendwie mit einer neuen Welle voraus sind, also die in eine vierte oder fünfte Welle gegangen sind
noch nicht. Wenn dann wahrscheinlich die die Schweiz, könnte ich mir vorstellen, die geht dann am ehesten noch in so eine,
neue Welle zu gefühlt.
Na, was würdest du denn da so als Grund herausarbeiten? Ich meine, was ist denn jetzt so substantiell anders, außer der Impfquote? Und ein bisschen Wetter.
Mehrere Dinge. Also wir hatten zum ersten Mal tatsächlich also so starke so drastische Ausgangssperren, äh wie wir sie jetzt hatten in Berlin, hatten wir eigentlich während der ganzen Pandemie nicht.
Ja? Und äh ich habe das Gefühl, dass das äh äh einen,
ein Faktor ist gerade wahrscheinlich bei vielen Jugendlichen äh oder so und auch bei vielen, also besuchen in Privathaushalt, ne.
Gewalt von vielen Leuten gehört, äh so, die dann eben wegen der Ausgangssperre dann hm ja,
sich dann eben nicht getroffen haben oder dann zumindest
dann sagen konnten, ach nee du so mit der Ausgangssperre und so, ich bleibe mal lieber zu Hause, wenn dann halt so die Einladung kam, weil
ist dann halt auch oft schwierig dann irgendwie nein zu sagen, wenn jemand sagt, komm doch mal vorbei,
ähm ja und dann zu sagen, ah nee, wegen Corona bleibe ich mal lieber zu Hause. Das fällt vielen Leuten.
Schwer, wenn das so im Kollegen oder im Freundeskreis äh äh passiert und mit so einer Ausgangssperre kann man da eher nein sagen. Und,
wahrscheinlich haben die Eltern dann mehr drauf geachtet, dass äh die Kids äh dann halt also die Jugendlichen dann abends nicht mehr ausm Haus gehen oder nicht in dem Maße aus dem Haus gehen. Das wäre so,
ich sage mal, eine Vermutung, äh was halt ähm auch Einfluss gehabt haben könnte, weil das war neu.
Und ich hatte auch das Gefühl, äh dass abends tatsächlich dann äh wirklich.
Ziemlich Ruhe war in der Stadt, so verkehrstechnisch, also man konnte es einfach am Straßenverkehr schon hören, wie der dann irgendwie schlagartig äh,
irgendwann abgenommen hat.
Hm. Da wohnst du, glaube ich, ein bisschen günstiger, um das äh zu messen als ich. Ich habe so.
Straße nicht so viel Durchgangsverkehr, da ist es eh dann irgendwie ruhig, also von daher hat sich da nicht so viel verändert, aber es ist, ist schon richtig, also, ich meine, das wäre ja dann interessanterweise auch wirklich, wer war denn so für Ausgangssperren, das war doch auch der Lauterbach, ne? Der dafür getrommelt hat.
Weil dann war gar nicht so klar, dass das jetzt irgendwie so eine Wirkung haben könnte.
Nee, logisch ist das eigentlich nicht. Ja, logisch ist es also oder schien es zumindest zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht, aber äh Studien aus anderen Ländern hatten gezeigt, dass äh das halt funktioniert
Wahrscheinlich deswegen, weil die meisten Leute behaupten, dass sie abends sowieso nicht ausm Haus gehen und man annimmt, das abends sowieso nicht viel passiert,
an Kontakten ähm und dass deswegen keine Rolle spielen dürfte, aber vermutlich sind halt grade die riskanten Kontakte,
abends passiert. Das wäre meine These. So, ja, also zu Hause und in Privathaushalten so.
Aber ich meine, die Unternehmen, da hat sich ja eigentlich nichts geändert, oder?
Nicht viel. Ähm ich weiß nur, aber doch, also,
Es äh gab halt nochmal auch durchaus verstärkte Aufforderungen zu Homeoffice und eigentlich, sondern naja, im Prinzip eigentlich eine Homeoffice-Pflicht dort, wo es geht.
So faktisch. Hm, ja,
und äh ich habe jetzt keine Zahlen, ich habe mir die Mobilitätszahlen nicht nicht angesehen, aber ähm,
Ja, ich hatte das Gefühl, dass das schon äh das insgesamt äh ruhiger äh geworden war durch äh jetzt die.
Ähm ja soll man das Ding jetzt eigentlich nennen? Also sich die verschärften Maßnahmen durch die Bundesnotbremse.
Ja gut, wie schön wäre das gewesen, wenn man das einfach mal im Februar gemacht hätte?
Wäre das alles, dann wären wir schon längst durch irgendwie. Dann wäre alles offen und alles wäre supi und man könnte sich in Ruhe durchimpfen lassen und die Leute würden auch nicht ganz so in Panik verfallen, weil das scheint so ein bisschen.
Problem zu werden bei den Impfzentren. Hast du noch was zu den Zahlen.
Nö, ich glaub ja, das wär's, also irgendwo nix spektakuläres so.
Okay. Ja, genauso äh unspektakulär ist es eigentlich auch an der Impf äh Front.
Impfkampagne, also.
Hat so letzte Woche extrem äh geschwächelt, das lag halt so ein bisschen da dran, dass dass es erst so eine,
ja, noch mal so ein kurzes Aufbäumen gab, weil die ganzen Arztpraxen ihre Impfungen auf Montag, Dienstag, Mittwoch gelegt haben, weil dann Donnerstag eben Christi Himmelfahrt war und Freitag dann wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr so viel lief.
Beim Impfzentrum in Hamburg gab's so diesen Vorfall, dass dann nach diesem Wochenende auf einmal riesig lange Schlangen vor dem Impfzentrum entstanden.
Am Montag, weil ganz viele Leute so ihre Zweitimpfung geskippt haben.
Die wohl irgendwie auf diesen Samstag oder Sonntag fielen und die sich dann gedacht haben, och, langes Wochenende und so, dann gehe ich da mal Montag hin, weißt du?
Was natürlich dann zu totalem Chaos äh geführt hat, weil das natürlich,
Timing äh natürlich extrem äh wichtig ist, dass man weiß, mit wie vielen Leuten man's in etwa zu tun hat. Da sind sie dann richtig laut geworden, haben gesagt, Leute, macht das nicht, das ist einfach gar keine gute Idee.
Auch ansonsten, was ich so höre, haben die Impfzentren einfach,
Ja, mit so allerlei Problemen zu kämpfen, auf die man so vielleicht erstmal nicht kommen würde. Also müssen offensichtlicher vielleicht noch, ist einfach so,
entweder die Unfähigkeit oder die Unwilligkeit, Termine zu stornieren, wenn sie denn nicht wahrgenommen werden.
Da hast du so die Fälle, dass diese halt, was weiß ich. Leute sind halt bei mehreren Ärzten auf irgendwelchen Listen. Das ist so ein bisschen so wie Kitasuche im Prenzlauer Berg, so. Man probiert's irgendwie überall gleichzeitig und wenn man dann einen Zuschlag hat, naja, dann dann werden die Plätze langsam frei.
Dass da dann auch mal Bescheid gesagt wird in der Regel,
aber das hier wohl oft Leute dann andere Impfgelegenheiten haben und ihre zugesagten Termine dann einfach verfallen lassen. Entweder weil sie nicht dran denken das nicht für wichtig erachten oder weil's ihnen auch,
schwer gemacht wird
weil einfach das passende User-Interface dafür so nicht vorhanden ist. Und damit den Hotlines nicht durchkommt oder die Webseiten das nicht hergeben et cetera. Also so richtig sind diese ganzen Systeme ja nicht.
Damit haben die zu kämpfen. Was ich auch noch gehört habe, ist, dass die Leute.
Wie soll ich das sagen? Bisschen schwierig werden, also es kommt wohl vor, gehäuft vor, dass Leute jetzt einfach auftauchen, keinen Termin haben.
Und dann irgendwie sagen, ja ich bin hier Bürger, ich will jetzt geimpft werden und dann einfach schwierig sind.
Also weißt du.
In pampig werden oder halt auch einfach da sind und in dem Moment natürlich auch das Personal nerven und das Personal binden, weil du musst ja dann irgendwie damit klar,
kommen, du musst ja irgendwie mit diesen Leute,
irgendwie irgendwas muss ja mit denen machen, ne, weil die dann irgendwie rumschreien oder sich was weiß ich äh wie verhalten. Da hast du so alle Abstufungen,
Und ähm na ja, dann musst du halt irgendwelche Wege finden, damit umzugehen und da mag dann,
jedes Impfzentrum, jedes, jedes Personal andere Prioritäten haben, wie man da umgeht, ob man da jetzt irgendwie Härte zeigt, ob man irgendwelche Ausnahmen macht oder was weiß ich,
Aber das ist auf jeden Fall in zunehmenden Maßen ein Problem. Am Anfang hatten die's halt vor allem mit alten Leuten zu tun. Da war irgendwie klar, welche Hilfestellungen die brauchen.
Und jetzt ähm ja, hast du halt so diese Impfdringler, die dann einfach auf solche Systeme scheißen, beziehungsweise
die sich auch so ein bisschen von der Situation verhöhnt äh vorkommen, weil sie teilweise eben noch in Prioritätsgruppen fallen.
Eigentlich längst hätten versorgt werden sollen, aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen einfach keine Termine bekommen haben, weil es nicht geklappt hat oder so und jetzt äh hast du halt diese Diskussion,
kommen wir nachher auch nochmal drüber sprechen, so mit Jens Spahn, der gesagt hat so, na ja, jetzt demnächst heben wir mal alle Prioritäten auf
Und das war ja in Berlin auch so, da gab's eine totale Verwirrung, da hieß es so, ja, jetzt heben wir das auf
Dann haben sich die Ärzte beklagt und haben gesagt, sag mal, habt ihr sie noch alle? Wenn ihr jetzt irgendwie die, also wir haben jetzt schon den ganzen Tag hier irgendwie hundert E-Mails pro Tag und tausend Leute rufen hier an und alle wollen immer irgendwie auf irgendwelche Listen kommen,
fast gar nichts anderes mehr zu tun als nur mit diesen Leuten zu telefonieren, dann sollen wir sie irgendwie auch noch impfen,
Und jetzt kommt ihr auch noch und hebt diese Prioritäten auf. Dadurch wird dieser Ansturm noch größer, der aber einfach derzeit mit Impfstoffen überhaupt nicht bedient werden kann.
Also das kommt einfach so ein bisschen zu Unzeit. Und was wir auch schon ein paar Mal angesprochen haben.
Dass auch diese Prioritätsgruppen ja am laufenden Meter aufgebläht wurden. Ne, also ne, erst erst hieß es halt nur schwer Kranke und was nicht alles,
Das war auch alles nachvollziehbar. Und dann wurde eben so aus politischen Gründen immer wieder so äh die Gruppe dann nochmal mit anderen.
Fällen auch noch mit vollgepumpt und auf einmal waren hier in Berlin alle Universitätsmitarbeiter dann halt auch in Priorität drei. So.
Wie wie willst denn da auch irgendwie planen und dazu kommt noch, das haben wir ja hier auch schon besprochen in dieser ganzen Diskussion um den digitalen Impfpass. Das halt wahrscheinlich auch einfach gar nicht genug konkrete, wirkliche, belegbare,
und belastbare Daten vorliegen, wer denn jetzt eigentlich schon dran war oder nicht, in welchem Alter, so dass das halt einfach so eine pauschale Aussage ist,
Ich weiß ja nicht so ganz genau, was da so läuft im Bundesgesundheitsministerium, aber dieser Termin, der siebte Juni.
Erschien wohl den irgendwie ganz opportun zu sein. Und ich habe mir diesen Termin angeschaut, mich gefragt, so, was was,
Was qualifiziert jetzt eigentlich den siebten Juni für die Aufhebung der Priorisierung? Was was ist denn jetzt hier die Sprache in den Zahlen, die sagen würde so ab dann ist das kein Problem.
Und ehrlich gesagt, da habe ich relativ wenig gefunden. Weil wenn man sich jetzt mal anschaut, was passiert. Wir haben jetzt,
letzten Tagen eine enorm steigende Quote von Zweitimpfungen. Wir sind da so noch vor kurzem waren wir so bei bei,
zehn, fünfzehn Prozent und das ist jetzt irgendwie hochgeschnellt auf vierzig Prozent und wir werden im Verlaufe der nächsten Woche wahrscheinlich sehen, dass einfach der Großteil der Impfungen, die durchgeführt werden, einfach Zweitimpfungen sind, weil der Bedarf ist halt einfach dafür da, ne. Es sind halt einfach Erstimpfungen
sind äh so Anfang April
hochgeschossen und jetzt ist halt Mitte Mai und jetzt sind die sechs Wochen rum. Und jetzt, ja, jetzt müssen diese Leute halt bedient werden, ne. Äh ist ganz klar,
So, das heißt, wir werden eben jetzt ein entsprechendes Ansteigen sehen, aber es ist halt so, dass wir die letzten Wochen konstanten Impfstoffversorgung haben. Das heißt, es gibt,
nicht noch zusätzliche Impfstoffe für diese Zweitimpfung und dann geht das halt zwangsläufig von den Erstimpfungen weg.
So und das hatten wir, glaube ich, auch letzte Mal schon gesagt, dass also Niedersachsen ja schon angekündigt hat, wir machen jetzt erstmal nur zwei Wochen nur äh nur Zweitimpfung und ich habe das jetzt auch aus anderen Landkreisen schon gehört, also das äh verbreitet sich gerade.
Vielleicht noch, weil wir vorhin die Faktoren hatten,
zu sagen, warum der R-Wert äh äh runter äh geht und Motivation äh vielleicht aufzuheben ist, weil vielleicht sparen auch mitbekommen hat, ähm dass äh Leute.
Impftermin äh sich tendenziell,
äh seltener anstecken, weil sie mehr aufpassen, weil sie jetzt auf den letzten Metern es sich jetzt nicht noch äh einfangen äh wollen. Das heißt, das könnte halt vielleicht auch noch mit eine Rolle spielen. Ansonsten ja.
Ja, aber die Leute kriegen ja keine Termine. Das ist ja das Problem. Es gibt,
nur Termine wirklich, denn wenn eure entsprechenden Impfstoff vorhanden ist. Und ähm man hört wirklich die Abenteuerlisten äh Sachen, also bis hin zu jemanden, dem irgendwie jetzt einen Termin so in
im Oktober in Aussicht gestellt wurde bei irgendwelchen Arztpraxen, wo ich sagen muss, das ist wirklich vollkommen äh illusorisch, weiß ich nicht, wie
die das sehen, aber das mag da äh jetzt auch so eine individuelle Perspektiv
äh eine Arztpraxis gewesen sein. So oder so ist also jetzt der Schnitt der Erstimpfung ein bisschen runtergegangen und auch so die äh.
Der der Impfung an sich hat so ein bisschen äh gelitten unter dem Feiertag, das werden wir jetzt halt über Pfingsten auch haben. Trotz alledem.
Sind jetzt die Zahlen,
soweit ganz gut, wir sind also kurz davor vierzig Prozent der Bevölkerung mindestens einmal geimpft zu haben.
Also wir sind jetzt bei ähm lass mich raten. Nein, lasst mich nicht raten, lasst mich nachschauen. Wir haben neununddreißig Komma drei vier Prozent Erstimpfung und.
Über dreizehn Prozent Zweitimpfung oder vollständige Impfungen, um's korrekt zu formulieren. Und letztere werden halt jetzt äh ständig ansteigen.
Ja und wo sind wir denn dann in der ersten Juniwoche, wenn äh diese ganze Priorisierung aufgehoben wird, dann sind wir.
Also wenn's gut läuft oder so läuft, wie ich mir das jetzt gerade so ausmale.
Dann sollten wir so am Ende der ersten Juniwoche, also zum siebten Juni, sollten wir fünfzig Prozent Erstimpfung haben.
Ja
Vielleicht war das ja auch die Kalkulation so nach dem Motto, okay, fünf ungefähr also die Hälfte der Bevölkerung äh sind priorisiert. Ja und wir müssten eigentlich dann tatsächlich auch,
mit den Prioritätsgruppen durch sein theoretisch oder?
Na ja, ne, ich kann dir sagen, was du dir was die Motivation wahrscheinlich wahr, nämlich schlicht und ergreifend, dass ab der Woche nochmal anderthalb Millionen mehr Impfdosen von Biotech geliefert werden. Das ist also äh erster Juniwoche, das ist so der Zeitpunkt, wo
anderthalb Millionen mehr Impfdosen pro Woche kommen,
und dann eben auch den ganzen Juni über. Also wir haben quasi einen Anstieg der der Impfdosen um anderthalb Millionen, aber ich sage auch mal halt auch nur.
Äh anderthalb Millionen.
Pro Woche jetzt.
Pro Woche, genau, ne? Also jede Woche werden anderthalb Millionen mehr geliefert, als es vorher waren. Und ähm also in absoluten Zahlen.
Kann ich das auch nochmal äh nachschlagen, wobei diese Prognosen, die da auf der Webseite sind, die sind auch so ein bisschen äh ominös,
Aber wenn ich's äh alles richtig erfasst habe, wir sind halt derzeit jetzt in der.
KW9, also jetzt in der letzten Woche wurden fünf Komma eins fünf Millionen,
ähm Impfdosen geliefert in den zwei Wochen davor war es jeweils nochmal
etwas mehr, also fünf Komma acht Millionen ist bisher so der Rekord in KW siebzehn und für die nächste äh Woche ist halt wieder etwas weniger, vier Komma neun, für die KW einundzwanzig,
sind's nur vier Komma fünf Millionen. Also es geht sozusagen auch nochmal ein bisschen runter. Das kommt noch dazu. Und dann erst.
Ähm zu KW zweiundzwanzig.
Für die erste Juniwoche sozusagen. Dann geht's halt dann schlagartig hoch auf sechs Komma vier Millionen.
Und pendelt sich dann so um um sechs bis sechs Komma zwei irgendwie ein,
Das ist jetzt nicht so mega viel mehr, weil es sind ja auch mehr Leute noch erst geimpft worden in den letzten Wochen, die dann auch wieder in die Zweitimpfung reinkommen. Und das wird dadurch halt so ein bisschen aufgefressen. Also ich sehe jetzt nicht so eine ganz klare,
klaren Grund, ne.
Mir fiel grade noch ein, es könnte sich aber tatsächlich auch um ein rechtliches Problem handeln, weil mir kam gerade der Gedanke,
Ähm wenn du jetzt Impfungen priorisierst so
und du hast aber jetzt plötzlich sechzig oder siebzig Prozent der Bevölkerung sind priorisiert, kann man eigentlich nicht von Priorisierung reden, sondern einem Impfverbot für dreißig Prozent der Bevölkerung. Ja
äh also äh sagen dann wär's äh ist es dann langsam sozusagen nicht gerechtfertigte äh Diskriminierung äh ja, die da an der Stelle äh stattfindet, könnte ich mir vorstellen, an irgendeinem Punkt,
ja und den Punkt bei ungefähr fünfzig Prozent zu liegen, halte ich jetzt auch äh für ähm ja,
nicht absurd, weil äh nämlich, wie gesagt, also ich finde, ab fünfzig Prozent kann man nicht mehr wirklich von Priorisierung reden.
Oder wie siehst du das? Wie würdest du das äh sehen? Bin ich da irgendwie zu?
Also sagen wir mal so, vielleicht gibt's jetzt keinen Grund mehr für eine Priorisierung, aber so eine
Tigentierisierung wäre wahrscheinlich gar nicht so schlecht
Also mal ganz abgesehen davon, dass in dieser Priorisierung ja so eine so eine Art Impfgerechtigkeit ist mit die, die sie jetzt am dringendsten benötigen
die am meisten betroffen sind von schweren Verläufen zuerst, ja, die schwächsten zuerst. Und jetzt kannst du diese Abstufungen zunehmenden Maße nicht mehr so machen, weil ist der Unterschied zwischen fünfundvierzig Jährigen und fünfunddreißig Jährigen, Fünfundzwanzigjährigen so.
Ja
theoretisch sind die Fünfundvierzigjährigen noch mehr gefährdet, aber die Gefährdungskurven befinden sich mittlerweile so im Bereich, wo es sehr viel mehr von der persönlichen Fitness als vom Alter
abhängt, sage ich mal, ne. Und das Ding ist halt nur, wenn wir so ein Terminsystem hätten, was irgendwie so gut durchprogrammiert ist,
was mal der Bevölkerung da auch ein entsprechendes Interface äh bietet und und diese ganze Impf-Experience an der Stelle oder diese Impfterminexperiments auch mal äh erträglich macht,
Stattdessen haben wir tonnenweise,
irgendwelche Privatprojekte mit so metarimpfterminverteilern. Ja, also dass ihr eigentlich einen Impftermin-Interface ist, dann hast du davor gelagert irgendwelche Systeme,
von Startups, Firmen, Privatpersonen, die grasen diese Termine ab,
präsentieren sie dir auf eine andere Art und Weise, machen Wartelisten, um dir dann Bescheid zu sagen, dass hier grade irgendeine Gelegenheit aufgepoppt ist
ein ein Wildwuchs von was weiß ich, zehn, zwanzig Uhr Els, die du heutzutage benutzen kannst, wo du auch gar nicht mehr weißt, was dir dahinter steht
bis hin zu irgendwelchen Jugendlichen, die es vielleicht total gut meinen, aber dann irgendwie so Googles aufbauen und dann erstmal Name und Adresse und so weiter alles äh sammeln,
Leute das dann vielleicht auch noch eintragen, was weiß ich, wo die Daten dann äh landen.
So und das das ist einfach ein totales Drama, ja? Anstatt, dass es einfach ein System gibt, wo klar ist, okay, ich registriere jetzt hier meinen Impfwunsch.
Das wäre schon mal gewesen, dass man einfach sagt, okay, wir bauen jetzt mal ein System auf und wir sammeln jetzt erst mal alle Willigen. So und die willigen sagen, ja, ich bin irgendwie Alter und trallala und meiner Meinung nach gehöre ich in Kategorie sowieso.
Habe ich hier mir durchgelesen und wird jetzt vielleicht auch teilweise noch abgefragt. Also in irgendeiner Form könnte man das machen.
Was spricht dagegen so ein System zu bauen? Äh das ist durchaus möglich. Klar sind das viele Leute,
Datenschutz und lalala, aber man braucht es ja auch. Also man braucht so ein System. So und dann,
dann geht dieses System,
flexibel um und und und schickt einem regelmäßig Updates und und sagt, wie es aussieht und welche Möglichkeiten es äh gibt. Und das jetzt.
So und so äh so hoch in der in der in der Warteliste drin steckt so, wo nicht permanent irgendeine Aktivität ist. Leute verbringen Tage und Wochen damit wie die ganze Nacht auf irgendwelchen Webseiten Reloaded zu drücken, um danach überhaupt nicht mehr zu wissen, was was Sache ist
anstatt dass man einfach einmal irgendwo das eintippt und Ruhe hat, dadurch dass das System regelmäßig auf einen zukommt und sagt so, ja es ist mal wieder eine Woche vorbei
Das und das hat sich verändert. Guck mal so und so viele sind schon geimpft worden. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du demnächst einen Termin bekommst, ist jetzt irgendwie so und so gestiegen. Bleib mal ganz ruhig. Ich weiß, dass äh du wartest und so weiter.
Na ja, nachher lassen wir es immer besser.
Und man könnte dann in so einem System auch eine gewisse Impfgerechtigkeit
einbauen, indem man äh quasi, in dem das System halt so wöchentliche Impflotterien veranstaltet, äh sagen das alle, die sich dann innerhalb einer Woche registriert haben, die werden dann äh sagen.
Nach Zufallsprinzip, wenn.
Ja äh äh werden dann äh plus Priorität äh äh natürlich äh werden dann entsprechend äh zugeordnet so. Keine Ahnung, wie das jetzt gemacht haben, aber.
Jetzt für innerhalb der Altersgruppen, da gab's ja auch ganz unterschiedliche Verfahren, teilweise sind die wirklich nach alter runtergegangen so, immer so in Jahresschritt,
oder so äh gibt's sicherlich tausend Möglichkeiten äh äh des des äh zu tun, aber ja,
gebe ich dir völlig recht, äh das wäre wahrscheinlich, wenn wie die Bundesregierung irgendwie jetzt äh mal dann einen.
Starten möchte oder gut, es ist ja leider dann wieder Ländersache, aber eigentlich äh ja, wären äh wäre so ein.
Impfriorisierungssystem wäre,
wahrscheinlich äh etwas, was man haben wollte, wobei du das natürlich dann wiederum anpassbar machen musst, weil natürlich,
bei äh einer anderen Pandemie, bei einem anderen Virus, kann das halt anders aussehen äh mit der Betroffenheit, so mit den Kurven.
Wie stark betroffen ist und so, aber
noch besser natürlich als einen Impfriorisierungssystem wäre, die Investition in Produktionskapazitäten, dass man in der Lage ist
innerhalb eines Monats die gesamte Bevölkerung mit Impfstoff zu versorgen, dass wir, finde ich, so einen Level, so eine Produktionskapazität, die wir eigentlich,
vorhalten sollten. So wenn's nach mir ginge.
Okay, gut, na das ist jetzt so der Blick in die Zukunft und ich will auch gleich hinzufügen, weil das bestimmt dann äh auch in den Kommentaren kommt
Ja, ich weiß, es ist irgendwie ein schwieriges Thema und die Daten und so weiter. Aber ich halte das nicht für unmöglich. Ja, es ist äh auf jeden Fall möglich, dass äh das
System in gewisser Hinsicht zu verbessern. Und
ich weiß auch, dass man viele dieser Erkenntnisse, die ich jetzt vielleicht so zwischendurch jetzt grade mal so von mir gegeben habe, auch erst im Laufe dieses Prozesses wirklich erst kennenlernt und ich hätte die vielleicht vor äh sechs Monaten auch nicht so formulieren können
Aber ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass man nicht Leute da schon früher hätte drüber nachdenken lassen können. Und da geht schon was.
Egal, wie auch immer, es ist äh derzeit nur.
Eingeschränkt, zufriedenstellend für die Leute und deswegen gehen halt manche Leute auch auf dem Zahnfleisch. Kann ja verstehen, dass die Leute so ein bisschen bisschen durch sind, ja.
Auch so Signale wie wir wir lösen jetzt mal Impfzentren auf, weil die sind uns jetzt zu teuer.
Einfach nicht der Zeitpunkt, darüber zu reden. Ich glaube, dass wir diese Impfzentren noch noch sehr gut gebrauchen können.
Für äh viele, viele Monate, also mindestens bis äh bis in den Herbst hinein und vielleicht sogar auch dann noch, dass die also teilweise noch bis Ende des Jahres im Betrieb sein werden. Das wird sich zeigen.
Ähm aber mit solchen Signalen äh reicht man nicht viel.
Ja, ja. Ich meine, das Ding ist aber wohl auch, dass die halt äh sehr unterschiedliche Kosten verursachen. Ähm.
Mitbekommen von verschiedenen Leuten, die in Impfzentren äh arbeiten, wurden halt Preise von was äh von siebzehn Euro zum Beispiel in Sachsen im Schnitt pro Impfung äh in den Raum.
Geworfen, andere Zahlen habe ich gehört, die gingen halt über hundert Euro pro Impfung halte ich für durchaus plausibel auch, weil das natürlich von vielen Faktoren abhängt. Auch der Größe und äh,
Impfzentrum jetzt in irgendeiner Immobilie untergebracht ist, die sowieso leerstand und der dem Land gehört oder ob da halt irgendwie extra.
Irgendwie Bauten errichtet werden müssen und gemietet und so, wobei wahrscheinlich der Großteil sowieso die Personalkosten sein dürften.
Ja, es gibt ja auch genug Veranstaltungsräume, die jetzt ohnehin nicht genutzt werden konnten. Aber die müssen dann halt auch gemietet werden, ne, klar.
Und natürlich eine Problematik war wohl auch so ein bisschen äh dass halt die Impfzentren des Land bezahlen muss, während man das einfach auf den Ärzten überhilft, dann geht's halt aus dem Gesundheitsfond.
Also da ist auch teilweise wirklich falsche Knausrigkeit äh im Spiel, ne. Ich meine, in Berlin hattest du zum Beispiel diese Taxiregelung, ne? Es gab dann eben so Taxigutscheine für Leute ab einem bestimmten Alter, nämlich ab siebzig.
Aber so Hartz vier Leute, ja, die vielleicht auch krank sind, keine Chance.
Leute, die äh bis hin zu und das ist dann natürlich dann Einzelfälle. Ich habe da Geschichten gehört, das äh halt auch Ärzte nicht bereit waren, da einfach normale Krankenscheine aus oder Kranken, ich weiß nicht wie heißt das, Krankenfahrt.
Also Scheine für Krankenfahrten äh auszustellen für für das Fahren zum Impfzentrum.
Das für so was habe ich dann irgendwie auch äh kein kein Verständnis, ne. Ich meine, wir müssen das jetzt einfach nur so schnell wie möglich und so effizient und so, so, so reibungsarm, wie es irgendwie geht,
durchziehen und's jetzt einfach.
Sparen ist später, glaube ich, noch genug Zeit. Na ja, egal. Auf jeden Fall, um es mal zu summieren, es geht jetzt noch insgesamt noch ganz gut voran. Äh es kommen derzeit ungefähr vierhunderttausend Leute,
pro Tag äh neu unter die Nadel. Diese Zahl wird jetzt wahrscheinlich sinken in den nächsten zwei Wochen, aber danach äh gegen Ende,
Mai, Anfang Juni dann auch mit den höheren Impfstoff ähm Lieferungen wird es dann wieder hochgehen und wie gesagt, fünfzig Prozent irgendwann so äh erste Juniwoche halte ich für realistisch und ähm,
ohne es jetzt wirklich im Detail durchgerechnet zu haben, denke ich mal, dass wir so oft die sechzig bis fünfundsechzig Prozent kommen könnten Ende Juni,
und ja, im Juli wird's sich dann wirklich entzerren, äh dass dass dann einfach die Impfwilligkeit dann eher das Problem sein wird. Von dem ich hoffe, dass es nicht ein Problem sein wird, aber womit man auf jeden Fall rechnen muss.
Mir heute auch kurz durch den Kopf ging noch, weil fällt mir jetzt gerade ein, weil wir noch beim Thema impfen sind.
Ähm,
und zwar jetzt für die muss sagen für diese Nachweise ob du jetzt geimpft bist oder irgendwie vorher angesteckt warst oder so,
ähm äh habe ich gelesen, dass ein Antikörper-Nachweis irgendwie ausreichend sein soll.
Wir haben ja jetzt noch nicht genau angeguckt und hat mich dann gefragt, was ist eigentlich, wenn du irgendwie ein paar Tage nach der Impfung
Nach der Erstimpfung äh jetzt dir irgendwo noch so einen Antikörper-Nachweis, also über Antikörper äh besorgst. So und
dann halt erstmal mit dem Antikörper Nachweis einfach rumläufst und ja das quasi als äh ja durchgemachte Krankheit
erkaufst.
Ich glaube, das gilt aber nur im Zusammenhang mit mit äh einem einmaligen positiven PCR-Test.
Also keine Ahnung, also das ist, glaube ich, im Detail noch wirklich total unklar, wie das jetzt wirklich umgesetzt wird. Ich habe auch das Gefühl, da flirren mehr Ideen äh äh im Raum rum, als letzten Endes umgesetzt werden,
Diese ganze Impfausweisgeschichte hat einfach das Problem, dass sie ja, einfach auch wieder einen Druck erzeugt, den wir.
Vielleicht einfach gar nicht gebrauchen können, ne. Also wenn ihr's immer mehr davon abhängig gemacht wird, dann drehen natürlich die Leute, die immer noch kein Impfangebot haben, äh erst recht durch. Und dann wird sich das sowas einfach auch nicht durchsetzen lassen. Also ich in welchen Situationen.
Ich war heute bin ich irgendwie äh in Berlin über das Tempelhofer Feld,
gelatscht. Da war dann halt auch so eine Außengastronomie. Und na ja, das war dann halt auch so ein Jahr und dann setzt euch mal dahin und dann ist da irgendwie ein Luca-App-QR-Code irgendwie aufm Tisch, den natürlich kein Mensch interessiert.
So, das ist dann irgendwie so nachweis und ja und eigentlich müsstet ihr eigentlich müsstet ihr jetzt hier einen,
müsstet ihr ja auch einen positiven Coronatest haben, um jetzt hier irgendwie eine Wurst zu genießen auf äh.
Negativen, ja.
Äh ja und einen negativen ähm.
Mhm. Ja.
Und kann, könnte ja sein, dass das Ordnungsamt das mal checkt. So. Wo ich mir halt auch nur dachte, so ja, genau,
Und natürlich macht das dann irgendwie auch keiner. So, also weder kontrolliert es irgendjemand noch noch ähm weil diese Restaurants haben einfach kein Interesse daran, irgendwie ihre Kunden wegzuschicken.
Wahrscheinlich ein paar arme Schweine werden dran glauben müssen an denen dann so ein Exempel statuiert wird, die dann Pech haben irgendwie, aber ich äh glaube mal, ja, äh dass das einfach einen,
Vollzugsproblem auch einfach sein wird, weil wenn die Leute das einfach nicht einsehen, äh so und äh,
zumal halt äh diese Negativtests auch ja nur eine falsche Sicherheit bieten. Ja, das kommt ja noch dazu.
Ja du damit die Wahrscheinlichkeit äh vielleicht halbierst ähm das äh.
Ähm äh da jemand ansteckendes äh sitzt, so. Das mehr damit,
gewonnen, äh wenn du die Tische ein bisschen weiter auseinanderstellst. So
ja als als äh mit mit den Tests, ja? Vor allen Dingen, wenn sowieso dann meistens Leute an demselben Tisch sitzen, äh die sowieso die ganze Zeit miteinander abhängen, ja.
Ja, eben. Und ich meine, es war heute zwar so halbwegs okay, das Wetter, es hat so ein bisschen geschauert, aber es war vor allem viel Wind und es war einfach.
Mir auch.
Auch ich konnte da nicht irgendwie jetzt da stehen und und und sagen so in so einem totalen Selbstgerechtigkeit, so nein, ich muss jetzt irgendwie an die Regeln halten, weil es einfach offensichtlich in dem Moment völlig irrelevant war,
und äh in gewisser Hinsicht kann man jetzt nur hoffen, dass die Leute genug darüber gelernt haben, was eigentlich eine,
Risikosituation ist für sie und was nicht?
Dass das jetzt einfach auch zur Anwendung kommt. Vielleicht ist das auch nochmal so ein Faktor, in dem wir bisher so noch gar nicht besprochen haben. Das wäre jetzt einfach.
Pandemieprofis geworden sind. Ja, wir haben's jetzt alles fünfzig Mal gehört und tausendmal durchgespielt und irgendwie, ja, wir wissen jetzt Bescheid. Wir müssen hier ein bisschen Abstand halten müssen und so, da passt schon irgendwie, gib her die Wurst.
Das ist einfach vielleicht auch ein bisschen funktioniert.
Und,
Ein weiterer Faktor, ich weiß gar nicht, wann das eigentlich so richtig los ging mit den FFP zwei Masken. Das ist eigentlich irgendwie mit, weil äh irgendwann hatten halt fast alle die Leute, die ich gesehen hatte, nur noch äh FFP2.
So
Das ist das ist wirklich also ich wundere mich immer schon, wenn jemand irgendwie noch eine normale Mund-Nasen-Schutzmaske trägt.
Das ist in der Tat ein ein Faktor. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, es wird wahrscheinlich ein Kostenfaktor gewesen sein, dass die Dinge einfach günstiger geworden sind. Und dass jeder irgendwie gesagt hat, so, ja, wenn schon Maske, dann wenigstens richtig.
Weil man die sowieso irgendwie ähm für bestimmte Dinge brauchte und dann nimmt man doch lieber ähm ja grundsätzlich eine FFP zwei äh Maske mit. Also ich habe auch im Moment,
nur irgendwie FFB zweis einstecken, wenn ich unterwegs bin und gar keine OP-Masken im Moment.
Also.
Ich glaube nicht, dass wir mit diesem Ausweis da noch sehr viel Realität sehen werden. Es wird versucht werden, diese digitale Geschichte einzuführen, aber ich glaube, es wird einfach an einer Kontrollrealität einfach scheitern.
Am Ende vielleicht für irgendwelche Flüge oder so, also wo du wirklich eine eine harte Tür hast. Ja, also,
den Situationen, da wird es vielleicht zum Einsatz kommen.
Und da mag es auch entscheidend sein, aber so in dem allgemeinen hin und her und gerade so im gastronomischen Bereich, glaube ich, werden die weiterhin da irgendwie ihre komischen Luca-App, QR-Codes auf irgendwelche Tische draufkleben, die keinen interessieren. Und die auch nichts bringen.
Weil, was soll das? Und irgendwann redet da keiner mehr drüber.
Gut, lass uns den Impf und Impfkontrollbereich äh abschließen.
So ein paar Kleinigkeiten. Äh wir hatten ja hier neulich äh diese Patente äh Diskussion. Dazu habe ich noch einen Nachtrag,
gibt eine Studie, die bei Nature veröffentlicht wurde.
Und das ist eine äh das heißt so schön in Network Analysis auf Covid-Ninets. Und da hat sich jetzt mal eine Gruppe die Mühe gemacht und tatsächlich mal die ganzen
Patentverflechtungen zwischen den einzelnen äh Unternehmen rausgemalt,
werden jetzt eigentlich woran Patente hält und mit welchen anderen Entitäten Verträge darüber bestehen oder gemeinsame Patente vorliegen.
Und es ist ganz interessant, weil man dadurch mal sieht äh in diesem schönen Diagramm, was dann da auch dabei ist, wer eigentlich so diese Player sind, weil bisher haben wir halt immer nur so von Biontech gehört im Wesentlichen und moderner.
Ja? Und das sind auch die zwei,
zwei von den wichtigeren ähm Gruppen in diesem Spiel, aber eben auch, worüber wir aber auch schon gesprochen haben,
das Unternehmen aus Deutschland, was äh im Prinzip im RNA, also die.
Der Ingmar Höhr, der das Unternehmen gegründet hat, der, der ist ja derjenige, der überhaupt auf diese Idee gekommen ist.
Vor über zwanzig Jahren und das das war so sein äh Moment, also Kürwerk moderner Biontech,
die meisten Patente oder die wichtigsten Patente, aber es gibt noch so ein paar andere Unternehmen, wo die ich noch nie was gehört habe,
Therapeutics, UBC, Akuvitas, Arobutus, et cetera, äh Phaser ein bisschen, also.
All die spielen in dieser Gemengelage eine Rolle und das äh haben wir als Link in den Shownotes und da könnt ihr mal draufgucken, um euch mal so ein bisschen einen,
ähm Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, wer da gerade mit wem was wie lizensiert et cetera. Ist auf jeden Fall ein ziemliches Geflecht.
Und es sieht so aus, wenn die kleinen Punkte, weiß ich nicht, sind die kleinen Punkte eigentlich die Patente?
Die Patente oder die Deals genauer.
Weise, was um was es sich handelt, also ob's ein gemeinsames Patent ist oder ob's auch die Anfechtung äh von Patenten ist, also auch die Auseinandersetzungen, die da laufen, die kommen dann auch noch mit rein.
Ich würde so sagen, auf einen Blick, das sind so ungefähr vierzig bis fünfzig Patente ungefähr, die da äh erfasst sind, so größenordnungsmäßig. Ja oder Deals und Lizenzen, also.
Genau, dir irgendwie da noch mit dranhängen.
Ja. Mehr kann ich dazu nicht zu sagen, weil ich das jetzt nicht im Detail ausgewertet habe, was äh diese Patente alle besagen und welche Wichtigkeit sie haben, aber wen's interessiert, ist in den Shownotes.
Wobei ich sehe auch, ich glaube, die äh da sind jetzt natürlich nicht die Grundstoffpatente wahrscheinlich drin oder so, also zur Herstellung verschiedener Grundstoffe. Wenn man das wahrscheinlich noch reinnehmen würde, dann kann man's endgültig vergessen.
Genau, wobei die Grundstoffe ja nicht im RNA spezifisch sind, sondern die gehören ja zu diesem ganzen Sektor. Das sind jetzt nur diese sich explizit auf diese MRNA im Stoffgeschichte beziehen.
Ja, dann ähm.
Gibt's nochmal Nachrichten aus UK zum Thema indische Variante von ZARS CoV zwei. Das äh B eins, sechs, eins, sieben.
Auch noch in der Unterscheidung mit Punkt eins und Punkt zwei. Frag mich nicht, was der Unterschied ist. Auf jeden Fall
ich hier was aufgegriffen, ähm das Sage, das ist so dieses wissenschaftler, diese Scientific Advisor Group,
das ist so quasi das, was was Deutschland nicht hat, so ein so ein offizielle Uns Government angeschlossene Wissenschaftsabteilungen, die halt in Notfällen äh gebildet werden.
Zu einer Beratungsgruppe.
Ja, wir haben halt wir haben ja bei uns irgendwie,
ähm ähm ist ja gut, wir haben halt äh letztlich das RKI und das das Py, die ja im Prinzip,
auch an die Regierung angegliedert sind und dann gibt's ja noch das Corona-Kabinett äh bei uns.
Das Corona-Kabinett. Ach, wirklich, sowas gibt es.
Wobei das im Prinzip eigentlich äh äh nur einen regelmäßiges Treffen von,
bestimmten Leuten,
ist die äh auf zum einen auf Ministeriallebene, aber auch nicht nur jetzt ministerielle. Das ist, glaube ich, das, was es bei uns gibt. Aber ja, wir waren bei äh B eins, sechs,
eins sieben zwo und das sieht auf den ersten Blick ja nicht so irgendwie beruhigend aus, was die da geschrieben haben.
Ja, also ob es beunruhigend ist, ist jetzt nochmal eine andere Frage. Auf jeden Fall
dieses gibt halt dann entsprechende Pepper raus, das haben sie halt irgendwie auch gemacht, weil sie eben davon ausgehen, dass diese Variante
nochmal deutlich übertragbarer ist als die B eins eins sieben, die in UK ja nur die kennt Variante genannt wird, weil sie sich in der.
Kennt durchgesetzt hat. Für uns ist das ja einfach der England-Virus.
Wir lassen's einfach, weil die müssen da ja unterscheiden. Genau und es ist äh fünfzig Prozent Mordtranspisible, wie sie so schön äh schreiben.
Sie sie schreiben genauer gesagt, ganz vorsichtig ist, ist möglich und also ist eine realistische Möglichkeit, dass es.
Es scheint so zu sein, dass es diese britische Zurückhaltung. Genau.
Wobei man muss jetzt immer auch noch unterscheiden, das heißt jetzt nicht, äh UK wird überrollt davon, sondern unter den wenigen Fällen, die sie überhaupt noch haben, besetzt sich diese Variante halt stärker durch.
Ähnlich wie wir das halt hier mit B eins eins sieben auch hatten und äh insofern gilt hier auch das, was für B eins eins sieben gilt
Ist nicht so, dass man dieser Variante eben nicht mit entsprechenden Methoden beikommen könnte. Erstmal helfen die Impfstoffe, zweitens sind halt die ganzen anderen
auch hilfreich, aber na ja, das muss dann auch angesetzt werden.
Also ich finde, das ist schon eine etwas spektakuläre Nachricht, wobei nämlich die Frage ist, ob die,
sagen, unter welchen Bedingungen diese fünfzig
Prozent dann äh zustande kommen, ob das ein Unterschied macht ähm ja, ob die irgendwie einen besonderen Weg gefunden haben oder einen Kniff, äh einen Verbreitungsweg,
der.
Der so ein bisschen aus dem Auge äh verloren gegangen ist. Vielleicht, ich hatte ja schon gemutmaßt, dass Fechten Virus jetzt, wenn die Leute.
Äh das Gefühl haben, okay, Schmierinfektionen sind jetzt nicht mehr so das Problem und sich und sagen weniger häufig die Hände waschen, was, glaube ich, faktisch der Fall ist. Es sei am Anfang noch viel krasser. Und dann ein Virus jetzt
die Idee kommt halt, dass irgendwie diesen Verbreitungsweg dann wieder ein bisschen besser zu nutzen. Keine Ahnung, äh was es ist, aber ich finde,
Also wenn sich diese fünfzig Prozent äh ansteckender als B eins eins sieben finde ich äh halt schon erstmal einen ziemlichen Hammer, ja.
Ja, ist ein Hammer, weil es bedeutet dann äh unterm Strich, dass wir mittlerweile auch bei SARS-CoV zwei in dieser Variante, wenn ich's jetzt richtig mitbekommen habe, bei so einem Naturer, so einem R0 von vier angekommen sind.
Während wir, glaube ich, mal mit zweieinhalb gestartet sind.
Ja, war eigentlich sogar zweieinhalb, dreieinhalb äh war halt.
Sagen, äh also eher dreieinhalb hatte man sogar, glaube ich, glaube ich, vermutet und ich hätte, würde dann eher fast, ja, also.
Auf jeden Fall äh ja, ist es nicht gut. Das ist nicht gut für, ich sage mal so was wie für das Thema, ja gut, Herdenimmunität in all seinen Varianten äh oder so
aber es ist halt auch nicht gut für den Herbst oder so, ja, wenn äh.
Wenn das oder überhaupt für jetzt die ganzen Lockerungen äh so das also.
Ja, also ich finde das beunruhigend, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, das könnte es sein, ne? Also es ist auf jeden Fall was bedeutet denn das eigentlich? Das heißt, also das Virus ist an sich jetzt nicht gefährlicher,
sondern es verbreitet sich eben nur leichter. Und das ist ja überhaupt bisher sagen wir mal so die primäre.
Adaption, die wir jetzt gesehen haben, aber diese ganzen Varianten anschauen. Also bisher hat sich keine,
Variante jetzt wirklich so als ultimativ viel tödlicher erwiesen, auch B eins eins sieben nicht?
Sondern die Optimierung, die das Virus durchführen kann, ist halt in irgendeiner Form,
ähm dafür zu sorgen, sich noch besser ausbreiten zu können. Sei es, dass diese Zeit, in der es sich verbreiten kann
länger ist oder dass es eben bessere Strategien hat, den Körper dann auch konkret zu übernehmen und gegebenenfalls mit weniger Viruslast
auch schon so effektiv ist. So, das das ist eigentlich das Ding. Das bedeutet aber im Umkehrschluss auch, dass alle unsere Maßnahmen, die wir bisher so auf den Tisch gebracht haben, an sich
in der Lage sind.
Des Virus auch in diesen neuen Varianten erfolgreich zu bekämpfen. Masten helfen nach wie vor, Abstand hilft nach wie vor und vor allem hilft impfen,
und das ist ja das Wichtigste.
Wobei äh ich glaube, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das auch die gleiche Variante war. Es war heute bei mir äh gescrollt, das glaube ich gegen diese äh nee, es war eine der südafrikanischen Varianten.
Ähm wo eine Studie jetzt rauskam, dass äh Astra Senica äh äh gar nicht gegen diese Variante äh hilft.
Was in in wieder in so Petrischalen Tests oder äh.
Ähm ne, ich, nee, nee, das war schon ähm irgendwie Zahlen.
Da gab es halt eine Variante, eine was war die südafrikanische, wo man,
dann mit Placebo verglichen hat und es keine Unterschiede gab zwischen Placebo und mit Astra, Geimpften.
Jetzt nur spezifisch aber auf diese eine Variante.
So richtig sozusagen Gruppenvergleich mit Leuten, die sich neu infiziert haben oder äh dass man Serum genommen hat und das dann.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, so eine also eine normale Impfstudie äh war das in dem Sinne halt äh Leute haben halt Impfstoff und Placebo gekriegt und äh.
Die Leute, die geimpft waren, haben sich danach mit dieser Variante angesteckt.
Ja genauso, also sozusagen in in gleicher Zahl angesteckt äh wie die Leute, die das Placebo gekrieg.
Und dann auch mit den selben schweren Verläufen. Okay, dann muss er mal diese diesen Link mal raussuchen, nicht dass wir das jetzt nur erwähnen.
Den muss ich.
Noch nicht gesehen. Haben wir ja schon Angst machen, dann dann auch wenigstens mit.
Also äh ja, aber die äh
Ja, aber die Variante ist hier halt noch nicht und wahrscheinlich spielt es dann äh ohnehin erst dann eine Rolle, äh wenn
sowieso eigentlich die nächste Impfung fällig ist, weil äh und wahrscheinlich müssen wir uns aber drauf einstellen, dass wir irgendwie alle sechs äh sechs Monate uns jetzt äh impfen lassen müssen erstmal bis auf Weiteres.
Kann ich nur sagen. Gut. Kommen wir äh zu den guten Nachrichten. Besseren Nachrichten.
Impfstoffe, gab ein paar interessante neue Meldungen und Erkenntnisse.
Zunächst einmal gab's gute Nachrichten von Biontech. Die haben nämlich weitere Tests abge,
und bei der IMA auch entsprechendes Material vorgelegt und jetzt sieht's so aus, als ob entgegen den früheren Spezifikationen der Biontech Impfstoff.
Bei normaler Kühlschranktemperatur, also zwei bis acht Grad, nicht nur wie bisher für fünf Tage gelagert werden,
und noch weiter verwendet werden kann, also ungefähr so eine Woche, so eine Impfwoche. Ne, das heißt, das Zeug kommt irgendwie beim Arzt an, muss dann in der Woche weg.
Sondern sie haben's überprüft und äh getestet und der Auffassung, dass es überhaupt gar kein Problem ist, den Impfstoff einunddreißig Tage lang bei dieser Temperatur vorzuhalten.
Ja, also im also jetzt äh aber in einem ähm Gefrierschrank äh einem normalen Laborgefrierschrank oder äh äh ach so zwo bis acht Grad. Oh, ja. Mhm.
Nichts nichts, was jetzt ein handelsüblicher Kühlschrank nicht bei entsprechender.
Mhm.
Auch hinbekommen sollte, ne. Wenn wir vielleicht einen haben, der.
Ausfallsicher ist, aber das ist auf jeden Fall jetzt möglich. Und das erlaubt natürlich den Biotech Impfstoff noch flexibler einzusetzen.
Also du kannst ihn halt einmal äh tiefgefroren äh an bestimmte Verteilungsorte bringen,
aber dann eben normal gekühlt weiter verteilen und dann kann er noch einen ganzen Monat lang benutzt werden und das äh ist natürlich gerade so für Arztpraxen und auf dem Land äh,
sinnvoll.
Erfreulich.
Dann gab's eine schöne Studie aus Spanien und,
Diese Studie hat sich der Problematik angenommen äh was ist denn, wenn Leute, die eine.
Eine Impfung mit astrainer erhalten haben, als Zweitimpfung den Biotech Impfstoff bekommen.
Und das ja jetzt nicht nur so eine theoretische Überlegung, sondern es ist ja tatsächlich auch die Empfehlung, dass die in Deutschland bereits jetzt, dass eben Leute, die ähm sagen wir mal jetzt unter den aktuellen Regelungen
gar nicht mehr für Astrasinika in Frage kommen würden, also unter sechzig, ne,
Diese äh Problematik ja schon mehrfach diskutiert, dass die halt ihre Zweitimpfung jetzt auch tatsächlich mit Bier und Tech bekommen sollen.
Ich weiß auch nicht, vermute mal, das könnte auch schon äh passiert sein. Da habe ich gar keine Informationen dazu. Auf jeden Fall gab's jetzt beim
Health Institut Carlos der Dritte in Spanien, eine Studie mit dem Namen Kombiwachs und die hat genau das untersucht. Das war so eine
Phase zwei, Studie, so eine randomisierte und ja, die haben sich das mal angeschaut und haben,
sehr positive äh Ergebnisse geliefert. Also.
Die haben also drei verschiedene Messmethoden gehabt ähm mit unterschiedlichen Bewertungen. Ich da ich
da ich die nicht so richtig verstanden habe zu dem Zeitpunkt habe ich mir das jetzt im Detail nicht aufgeschrieben, aber andere Berichte haben das so zusammengefasst, dass einfach die
Bildung der Antikörper bis zu bis zu Faktor dreißig, vierzig höher war, als wenn man auf Asrasinika einfach nur Astrasinika drauf brummt oder auch im Biotech und Biotech
Also diese heterogene Impfung.
Indem man einfach zwei technisch verschiedene Impfstoffe verwendet, scheint so ein richtiger Knaller zu sein.
Ja. Ich meine, die Vermutung haben wir ja schon länger geäußert und ich finde das immer sehr schön, wenn dann irgendwie Studien rauskommen, die irgendwie unsere Annahmen oder Mutmaßungen bestätigen.
Ist immer das Beste, ne? Ja, genau.
Und ich würde mal vermuten, das wäre mir dann auch äh noch öfter sehen in Deutschland, aber so die Leute, die sich jetzt quasi zu einer äh Astrasinika-Impfung,
durchgerungen haben oder es einfach zugeteilt bekommen haben, aber die ihre Zweitimpfung noch nicht bekommen haben,
ist jetzt die Wahrscheinlichkeit relativ hoch, insbesondere die, die das bei Arztpraxen bekommen haben,
weil Asra geht im Juni zum Beispiel an Arztpraxen überhaupt nicht mehr raus. Also wer jetzt so in den letzten Monat äh geimpft wurde.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass überhaupt noch Astrasinika Impfstoff vorhanden ist, bei den Arztpraxen ist äh eher null und deswegen werden die dann einfach zum Biotech greifen und dann gibt's halt die.
Ja, wie heißt du das?
Kombi-Impfung.
Dann gibt's die Kombiimpfung, genau. Und die Kombiimpfung knallt so richtig, also zumindest, was die Antikörper betrifft. Was so die Nebenwirkungen betri,
keine Ahnung. Ich denke mal, dass äh äh dürfte dann immer noch sehr von einem selbst abhängen. Aber äh alles, was sie da an Reaktionen gesehen haben, war halt so der Normale Impfreaktionskram,
nichts besonderes aufgefallen, also absolut gute Verträglichkeit. Ja und das Ganze macht ja auch irgendwie Sinn, ne? Weil es ist sozusagen der Körper kriecht,
dasselbe auf einmal auf zwei verschiedene Arten und Weisen beschrieben. Erkennt die Ähnlichkeit und äh.
Einfach nochmal ein schärferes Bild, ne? Das ist nicht so, du fotografierst nicht dasselbe Motiv von einer Seite, sondern einmal so dreißig Grad links und einmal dreißig Grad rechts und kriegst dann einfach auch einen plastischen Gesamtergebnis.
Sozusagen impfen in drei D.
Plus speziell bei Astra ist halt der Vorteil äh dann äh auch noch, das hatten wir auch schon, dass dann möglicherweise vorhandene äh Immunität oder beziehungsweise vorhandene Antikörper gegen,
Vektor äh Virus.
Wegfallen, genau.
Dass die halt auch einfach wegfallen und ähm ja. Also ne.
Das ist gut, ne? Nehmen wir mit. Dann gibt's noch Ankündigungen, äh dass wohl doch noch ein neuer.
Impfstoff in der Pipeline ist in Europa und zwar von Sanofi in Zusammenhang mit Glaxos Klein.
Unternehmen, die kriegen auch immer immer längere Namen, weil die sich,
zusammen fusionieren. Und irgendwie scheint's da total üblich zu sein, dass auch keiner auf seinen Namen verzichtet. Wir werden dann einfach alle zusammengepappt. Wenn irgendwann Asthma äh klein kauft, dann heißen die bestimmt Astrasinika, Glaxus miss klein.
Mhm.
Podcast Fusion in Deutschland machen, das könnte auch noch sehr interessante Ergebnisse bringen. Handelt sich auf jeden Fall um ein Proteinbasierten Impfstoff.
Ähm das haben wir ja hier auch schon mal durchgesprochen, was heißt das? Wir haben.
Drei verschiedene Ansätze derzeit für Impfstoffen im Markt oder genau genommen haben wir eigentlich bisher nur zwei,
Nämlich einerseits eben diese vektorbasierten Impfstoffe, also die in ein anderes,
Virus, was ein bisschen modifiziert wurde, eingeschlossene äh Informationen, die dann in Zellkern gebracht wird, eben wie bei Asra Zenika oder bei dem Sputnik.
V, Impfstoff und dort geht dann eben der normale Prozess los aus dem Zellkan heraus, wird dann äh durch diese eingebrachte,
DNA wird dann entsprechende RNA erzeugt, die dann eben zur Produktion in der Zelle. Ähm das System anregt
dann eben die viel gepriesenen MR, Impfstoffe von Biotech und von moderner, die einfach direkt die RNA in die äh in die Zelle reinbringen, gar nicht mal,
in den Kern und dort einfach sofort die Produktion äh anregen und dann eben die Protein-Impfstoffe, wo sozusagen
die Zelle gar nicht erst genötigt wird, diesen dieses Protein zu erzeugen, damit es dann erkannt wird von der äh vom Immunsystem, sondern einfach das Protein direkt
gebracht wird. Das ist sozusagen schon vorproduziert und wird äh einfach in Endform äh reingebracht, sodass dann eben das Immunsystem sofort drauf reagieren kann. Das ist das, was Sanofi Galaxus mit kleinen,
im Sinn hat, so wie Nova-Wachs im Übrigen auch.
Mhm. Ich frage mich nur, ob die zusätzlich dann nicht auch, also im Verstärker brauchen bei dem Impfstoff, die das Immunsystem anstacheln.
Oder ob äh sagen die Proteine selbst äh äh genug äh Alarm äh machen.
Gute Frage kann ich jetzt gerade gar nicht so beantworten.
Auf jeden Fall ist dieser Impfstoff äh noch ein bisschen weit weg, weil der jetzt grade erst mal Phase zwei durch hat, sondern die machen jetzt also erst mal Phase drei. Das kann also auch noch dauern.
Und äh andererseits testen sie dann aber sowohl jetzt gegen den Wildtyp als auch gegen die Südafrika-Variante
und sehen das eher so als äh Kandidaten für eine Dritte Impfung, ne? Fahren aber auch schon ihre Produktion hoch und gehen so davon aus, dass sie Ende des Jahres,
mit in den Impfstoffmix reingegeben werden kann.
Die werden auch schon schneller gewesen, aber die hatten äh Probleme. Ist auch ganz interessant, ne. Also sie haben äh diesen Proteine äh gemacht und haben dann die ersten Versuchsreihen gestartet. Und dabei hatten sie irgendwie nicht,
Messwerte bekommen, die sie haben wollten,
sich aber raus, dass das gar nicht an dem Protein lag, was sie erzeugt haben, sondern sie haben generell zu wenig Impfstoff verabreicht,
die Reagenzen, die sie da verwendet haben, falsche Messwerte geliefert haben. Also dadurch haben sie quasi bei ihren Testreihen einfach zu wenig Impfstoff verabreicht,
und äh deswegen sind die ganzen Phasen zwei in die Hose gegangen und musste noch mal wiederholt werden,
hätte eigentlich schon funktionieren können, hat aber nicht, weil sie einen technischen Fehler vorher gemacht haben. Zeigt aber auch sehr schön.
Dieses Mehrphasensystem gibt, weil einfach immer wieder was schief gehen kann.
Ja, ich möchte ja nicht derjenige sein, äh der das verbockt äh hat, weil,
da da ist richtig, da ist das war ein richtig teurer Fehler, glaube ich, der.
Sagen doch mal nicht nur irgendwie die Phase zwei neu machen, sondern allein irgendwie was dort dann noch an entgangenem Umsatz und äh so, das ist ja das war teurer Fehler.
Nebenbei äh wurde in dem Zusammenhang auch noch bekannt, dass aber auch an einem Impfstoff arbeitet.
Was ich wenig überraschend finde, weil ich glaube, jedes Bio-Unternehmen, was derzeit jetzt äh nicht aufgewacht ist,
mal ganz schnell anfängt, jetzt hier in MRNA Technologie zu investieren, das äh kann sich wahrscheinlich in zehn Jahren sowieso vom Markt verabschieden.
Hatten wir ja eh schon mehrfach diskutiert im RNA ist.
Jetzt nicht nur eine Lösung für diese Pandemie, sondern das ist halt einfach der heiße Scheiß und da steckt jetzt so viel Geld drin und so viel Potenzial drin, dass äh glaube ich jedes größere
Unternehmen, was hier in irgendeiner Form, also in diesem medical Bereich arbeitet, hier einfach die Kapazitäten hochfahren muss, da werden wir sicherlich auch sehen, dass äh
China äh auch nachlegen wird, also alle werden da reininvestieren, weil sich einfach gezeigt hat,
so Klassenprimus ist in dieser ganzen Situation. Ja zum Schluss habe ich dann noch einen.
Schönen, kleinen Twitter, äh Stretch, den ich noch äh verlinke, den ich ganz interessant fand, der so ein bisschen zeigt,
wo eigentlich diese Impfstoffe tatsächlich aktiv werden. Und es soll Versuch mit Mäusen.
Und das zu dieser übliche Trick, man man spritzt den sozusagen den Impfstoff, aber hat dann eben auch noch diese,
äh wie nennt man das nochmal, gleich, wenn wenn das dann sozusagen so leuchtet und man das eben so visuell dann äh im Körper nachweisen kann, diesen Luministenz äh,
Tricksern,
keine Ahnung, genetische Veränderungen und so weiter, alles zu kompliziert. Habe ich mir nicht gemerkt. Auf jeden Fall weiß man, wo was passiert und ähm.
Man meint wohl, das sei auf den Menschen in gewisser Hinsicht auch übertragbar,
Tatsächlich ist also so, die haben da also die Mäuse quasi geimpft und dann mehr oder weniger dem Impfstoff dabei zugeschaut, wie er so im Körper umher wandert und wo, wo er dann noch vorhanden ist und wo Aktivität ist.
Und tatsächlich ist es wohl so, dass wenn äh der Impfstoff.
Also es ist jetzt MRNA Impfstoff mit äh in in Lipid Nanopartikel äh eingepackt so, also weiß jetzt nicht, äh ob das dann für zum Beispiel auch so gilt. Es geht ja jetzt hier jetzt nur um den MRNA Impfstoff und,
gibt's halt dann die Einstichstelle und da ist es halt irgendwie aktiv
und danach wandert kurzfristig ein Teil dieses Impfstoffs in Milz und Leber, was wo so Teil dieser normalen Blutbahnentransport äh Konsequenzen
ist da auch nochmal ein Tag aktiv, aber danach bleibt eigentlich alles im Wesentlichen an dieser Impfstoffstelle.
Was ganz gut erklärt, warum man da dann auch so nachhaltig für ein, zwei Tage so dieses.
Reaktionsgefühl so äh präsent hat. Das ist ja das, was eigentlich fast alle berichten, die geimpft wurden.
Ähm also tatsächlich ist dann eben die Einstichstelle auch so der der wesentliche Produktionsort von dem es ausgeht, das fließt jetzt nicht in den ganzen Körper rein.
Ja, also ähm ja, Entzündungsgefühl im Muskel halt, ja.
Genau. Ist ein schöner Srit und da kann man nochmal einiges drüber lesen. Ich habe dann überhaupt so in letzter Zeit.
Nochmal mit einiger Begeisterung so im im YouTube mir mal so Videos angeschaut mit so Proteinvisualisierung. Es gibt da ja dann doch wirklich eine ganze Menge Zeug.
Einfach faszinierend. Wirklich hin und weg.
Also einerseits davon, wie es ist und andererseits auch, was man schon weiß und was man auch visualisiert bekommt.
Der ganze Kram so dermaßen klein ist, dass man ihn eigentlich gar nicht wirklich richtig beobachten kann.
Aber die Erkenntnisse, die mittlerweile da mit diesen neuen Beobachtungstechnik, dieser Kryo-Mikroskopie vor allem äh gewonnen werden konnten in den letzten Jahren, da wirklich bahnbrechend.
Und hast dieses dieses ganze Gewese in einem, was man immer so als so schleimige.
Gesamtvorgänge eigentlich wahrnimmt. Ich meine, man nimmt ja seinen eigenen Körper eigentlich im Wesentlichen so als,
Schleimbeutel war. Ne, wir sind so so zusammengewürfelter Quatsch. Und es trifft einfach nur und alles so eklig,
Aber das ist dann einfach.
Auf der aller allerkleinsten Funktionsebene, da wo es wirklich drauf ankommt, eigentlich alles wunderbar wirklich kleine Nanomaschinen sind, die ihr Werkzeug,
die irgendwelche Molekülketten durch sich durchziehen und Punkt für Punkt abarbeiten, kopieren und so weiter. Das äh ja, überzeugt mich äh total. Wir sind,
eilig durch und durch digital.
Ja. Ja, ich habe jetzt noch so zwei kleine Dinge zum Schluss, wenn ja fast jetzt am Ende, glaube ich,
So das eine war auf Twitter bekannt gegeben so dass irgendwie anlässlich,
der Pandemie. Ich äh
mir darüber im Klaren geworden bin, dass es da draußen äh ja nicht nur wie Corona gibt, sondern eben einen Haufen auch anderer gefährlicher Krankheiten, gegen die man sich impfen lassen kann oder wo man sein
im Status vielleicht mal wieder aktualisieren sollte und das hab ich halt gemacht und hab mir dann jetzt so,
nochmal eine volle Ladung geholt. Einmal irgendwie,
gegen Titanus, Diphtherie, Keuchhusten und Polio in den einen Arm und Hepatitis A und B in den anderen Armen. Und äh ja.
War aber irgendwie auch äh alles halb so wild.
Viel allzu viel habe ich nicht gemerkt äh davon. Und äh ja äh und dann äh,
kam halt noch so interessantes äh Feedback. Also erstens Leute, die äh meinten, oh ja, super, muss ich, muss ich, sollte ich unbedingt äh auch äh äh machen plus so die Überlegung, wie viele.
Impfungen denn jetzt äh gerade noch vielleicht deswegen gemacht werden, weil jetzt gerade alle Leute ihren Impfpass rauskramen für äh,
Corona im Funk äh und dann zum Arzt kommen und äh der dann da drauf guckt und sagt, ja, warum sollen sie nicht jetzt auch noch vielleicht wieder Auffrischung für dies äh oder jenes, wer halt,
interessant zu sehen, ob das irgendwie tatsächlich eine Wirkung äh hat, aber ja.
Tatsächlich irgendwie muss ich, muss ich sagen, ich bin da tatsächlich nachlässig gewesen mit äh Impfungen, also weil mir lag, glaube ich, die letzte Impfung irgendwie dreißig Jahre zurück. Und.
Ernsthaft. Okay. Ja.
Ja, ich meine, so richtig toll war's bei mir jetzt auch nicht. Ich bin zwar so gegen das Meiste geimpft und habe auch, also es liegt jetzt nicht dreißig Jahre zurück, also allein schon, weil ich äh äh auch mal einen,
ein äh eine Influenza,
Info mir geleistet habe, muss aber auch mit erschreckend feststellen, dass die vom Dezember zweitausendneun war und ich so nicht die letzten zehn Jahre, dass ich eigentlich auch immer alles äh vor mir hergeschoben habe. Das äh ist auf jeden Fall nicht gut. Aber ansonsten
glaube ich irgendwie eine ganze Menge durch.
Interessant ist auch, dass ich dann in dem Zusammenhang mal geguckt habe, was für Impfungen denn sonst noch die STiko so empfiehlt,
und ähm da äh war gibt's noch so eine andere Kombination gegen irgendwie Masern, Mumps und äh Röteln.
Dann gibt's noch Windpocken aber diese also Masern Mumps und Röteln sieht die Empfehlung so aus.
Dass äh alle vor neunzehnhundertsiebzig geborenen, für die wird es nicht empfohlen, weil man davon ausgeht.
Dass damals äh sagen, diese drei Krankheiten noch so sehr so stark rasierten, dass alle vor neunzehnhundertsiebzig geborenen sich eigentlich angesteckt haben müssten.
Allerdings äh ja, also hm ähm es gibt wohl, also bei mir, ich habe mich dann gefragt,
äh wie sieht's denn bei mir aus, weil ich nie eine Impfung dagegen gekriegt habe. Masern konnte ich mich erinnern. Mumps und
weiß ich nicht, ob ich die je hatte, weil ich hatte da irgendwie so Symptome, aber die waren so minimal, äh dass ich noch nicht mal beim Arzt äh war, also es hätte sein können oder hätte auch nicht sein können jetzt belege ich halt gerade äh,
ähm was ich denn damit mache, wenn ich nochmal mit dem Arzt.
Drüber reden. Ähm ja und die zweite Sache, die mir noch äh in dieser Woche so aufgefallen oder untergekommen ist,
ist äh ja, dass äh also veranlasst war das durch die,
durch die Meldung, dass halt in Berlin es jetzt sechsundzwanzig Fälle der indischen Variante B eins äh sechs siebzehn,
gegeben hat und ich mich dann gefragt habe, äh wie kann das eigentlich sein?
Dass jetzt hier die ganzen Varianten äh eingeschleppt,
werden, während wir im Lockdown sind und andere Länder, äh also dann habe ich mir halt angeguckt, was sind denn jetzt aktuell im Moment so die.
Einreisebestimmungen überhaupt und,
Da ist es so, zum Beispiel aus Indien oder wenn hast du als Indas sogar keine Chance äh im Moment irgendwie nach Deutschland.
Ein Visum zu kriegen, weil die Konsulate in Indien die Deutschen zu sind. Also es wird halt ganz, ganz schwierig und wie gesagt,
äh und äh gibt's nur in absoluten Ausnahmefällen, wenn was weiß ich dein Kind hier,
Deutschland behandelt wird oder im Sterben liegt oder sowas und du dann unbedingt kommen musst, ansonsten aber so ist es so, dass es für Deutsche.
Und Europäer generell.
Keine Beschränkungen in dem Sinne gibt, also wenn du die richtige Staatsangehörigkeit hast,
dann kannst du halt einreisen äh so und du wirst dann aber und du musst einen negativen Test vorweisen, allerdings ist es auch ein schlechter Witz, weil das geht halt auch.
Sagen denn,
Anti-Gen-Schnelltest so äh Anti-Gen-Schnelltest, der dann nicht älter als zwei Tage sein darf oder einen äh äh PCR-Test, der darf dann irgendwie drei oder vier Tage alt äh sein,
so und dann wirst du nach, das wird aber bei der Einreise werden irgendwie weder Tests gemacht,
und du wirst dann halt einfach in die häusliche Quarantäne geschickt,
was ganz offensichtlich nicht funktioniert, weil irgendwie sonst ist nichts zu diesen sechsundzwanzig Fällen gekommen wäre, also muss sagen, bei drei Ausbrüchen,
sind dann haben dann diese Rückkehrer halt ihre Familie angesteckt, ja?
Andere Länder handhaben, dass da teilweise ganz anders, also Schottland oder oder England ist es so, ähm dass du da erstmal in Hotel-Quarantäne gehst.
Und.
Die halt vorher auch bezahlen muss. Sind so, ich glaub irgendwie tausendfünfhundert oder tausendsiebenhundert Pfund oder so, die du da vorher abdrücken musst und dafür wirst du dann halt,
nach der Einreise direkt in 'nem Quarantäne Hotel untergebracht. In Kalifornien
ist es sogar so, dass du ein Hotel bezahlt kriegst, wenn du dich von deiner Familie absondern möchtest, wenn du dich jetzt infizierst
und aber nicht die Möglichkeit hast, irgendwie zu Hause äh äh wirklich dich abzusondern, dann kannst du einfach ins Hotel gehen und kriegst das bezahlt. Warum gibt's sowas bei uns eigentlich nicht?
Äh so habe ich mich dann gefragt, ja.
Pragmatische Lösung.
So, also äh sagen, das das hat mich halt so ein bisschen auch aufgeregt, weil wir hatten letzten Sommer eben schon die ganzen Reiserückkehrer, ja, die äh hier massiv äh Infektionen eingeschleppt haben
und äh so mich hat das halt einfach geärgert, dass wir hier jetzt Lockdown machen, ja, aber äh hier einfach Leute, Varianten ungestört einschleppen können, ohne äh dass da was gegen unternommen wird.
So was wirksames, ja? Und das hat mich halt schon so ein bisschen wütend gemacht. Ja.
Und äh ja, das war's auch äh im Wesentlichen, was ich noch so auf dem Herzen hatte.
Dann können wir ja mal zum Schluss kommen. Und den positiven Ausblick wagen.
Ja, also ähm,
Ich denke, die Inzidenzen werden bis auf Weiteres weiter fallen,
und das weitere dürften dann die Öffnungen sein und ja und es besteht eben.
Aus meiner Sicht eine hohe Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass wir äh in.
Zwei, drei Wochen äh ungefähr ähm ja die Zahlen aufhören könnten zu fallen und äh vielleicht sogar wieder etwas ansteigen so.
Dass äh dem würde ich halt eine gewisse Wahrscheinlichkeit, sechzig, siebzig Prozent oder so,
Wahrscheinlichkeit äh würde ich dem einräumen jetzt keine neunzig Prozent oder so, aber äh so in der Größenordnung wäre.
Meine Einschätzung. Und ansonsten hoffe ich, dass auch jetzt ab morgen oder übermorgen auch endlich.
Die äh Sterbezahlen äh nochmal runtergehen, dass wir dringend nötig, weil,
wir, ja, nach wie vor äh sagen, jetzt diese tausendzweihundertachtzig Leute in den letzten sieben Tagen gestorben äh sind und das.
Ist einfach zu viel. Das ist too much äh so, finde ich. Ja.
Aber das wird wird überhaupt nicht mehr diskutiert. Das ist einfach egal.
Nö, das läuft jetzt unter ferner Lief. Wir haben uns dran gewöhnt, dass irgendwie weiß ich nicht, hundert Leute jeden Tag äh sterben äh an einem Virus.
Gegen den es eine Impfung gibt und gegen den man sich schützen kann. So aber ja.
Dafür haben die Kaffees wieder auf. Ist auch was.
Ja, ja. Gut, ja.
Fairer Tausch.
Okay, üben wir uns nicht in zu viel äh Zynismus. Äh Impfkampagne wird in den nächsten Wochen und nächsten zwei Wochen vermutlich nicht so viele neue Leute in den Schutzbereich schieben können, wie es vielleicht wünschenswert wäre, aber dann im Juni
Juni geht's dann wieder richtig los. Ja und so oder so jede Spritze hilft, egal ob das Erste oder das zweite Mal,
dadurch wird zumindest an der Front alles besser und wir haben das erste Drittel durch immerhin, mehr als das so, ist ja auch schon mal was.
Ja und alle Leute, die jetzt äh vielleicht äh mit Astra erst geimpft sind, können sich darüber freuen, dass äh,
falls es ihnen gelingt, eine Biotech,
Impfung zu ergattern, wo man dann im Übrigen auch nicht so lange warten muss, äh wie mit der äh Zweit.
Impfung können sich dann halt darüber freuen, dass sie dann wirklich wahrscheinlich den derzeit bestmöglichen Impfschutz.
Impfsturz.
Den 3D Impfschutz äh äh bekommen so äh sagen, also ja, die die,
scheint halt so im Moment das Beste zu sein, was man sich so antun kann.
Zerstört wahrscheinlich schon aktiv Virus in der Luft, wenn man nur den Raum betritt.
Ja, ja gut, tatsächlich sind's äh irgendwie also einstellige Prozent
also man hat dann statistisch irgendwie statt vierundneunzig hat man dann sechsundneunzig Prozent oder ja.
Impfstoff mit Cape. Ja, es ist.
Und äh und wahrscheinlich äh hält äh da gut da gibt's jetzt noch keine Zahlen äh dafür, aber äh eben,
so ein so ein hoher Antikörper spricht auch potenziell dafür, äh dass das dann auch länger anhält, diese Kombo.
Gut Leute, das war's äh von uns. Äh wie immer, wir machen am Dienstag wieder unsere Feedback-Runde im Clubhaus
Diesmal dürfen auch die Leute mit Android-Telefon teilnehmen.
Äh in den Shownotes ist auch ein Link auf dieses Event und wenn ihr keinen Account habt, dann könnt ihr mit diesem Link auf den Event auch einen Account erhalten mit äh Worten. Diese Runde dürfte jetzt so ziemlich allen Leuten,
offen stehen, die daran teilhaben möchten und die über irgendeinen äh halbwegs aktuellen Smartphone verfügen. Das ist doch auch schon mal ganz schön. Ja und da würden wir uns freuen, wenn ihr
euch dazu schaltet, weil das waren bisher schon immer sehr nette und produktive Runden und jetzt kann's äh noch netter werden.
Sagen wir einfach tschüss und äh wir hören uns nächste Woche wieder.
Jo.